guillaume soro bonsoir bienvenue dont
vous êtes secrétaire général des forces
nouvelles
oui c'est à dire le chef des rebelles
ivoiriens qui contrôle le nord du pays
60% du territoire toi hein
vous êtes également ministre d'état
ministre de la communication du
gouvernement issu des accords de
marcoussis mais vous siégez par depuis
le 4 novembre effectivement je ne siège
pas au gouvernement pour des raisons
évidentes de sécurité
ouais bien sûr le 4 novembre 2004 on se
rappelle très bien que ça ce jour-là que
le régime de monsieur laurent gbagbo a
attaqué
n'est ce pas le nord de la côte d'ivoire
avec des avions de guerre et qui a même
posé la mort de neuf soldats français
ouais pour la première fois donc
guillaume soro le leader des rebelles de
côte d'ivoire s'explique dans un livre
qui s'appelle pourquoi je suis devenu
rebelle publié chez hachette
littératures alors avant d'en venir
précisément au contenu du livre encore
quelques mots sur vous guillaume vous
êtes né en 1972
vos parents sont catholiques mais votre
père était polygame quand même un oui
bien sûr
j'en ai ont fait rêver tous les français
en disant bien sûr penser que vous êtes
musulman nous pour fo les gardes et là
on découvre subitement qu'on peut être
polygame en étant catholique je les
ouvre des horizons guyomard je pense que
revient de femmes
combien de femmes de jeu que deux petits
bras deux cdc devant la wii wheel à la
fois donc parents catholiques père
polygame brillante élève guillaume au
départ vous avez la vocation de la
prêtrise et d'ailleurs vous faites le
petit séminaire
l'un cachola enfin le petit séminaire
est effectivement j'avais pour vocation
de devenir un pet et c'est vrai que il
faut être un peu conformiste pour être
prêtes et la vodka pas du tout
conformiste à l'adolescence de te déjà
un leader
vous êtes révoltez vous milité dans les
mouvements étudiants peintre et où vous
avez pris en compte
le social oui après le petit séminaire
où on nous a appris les valeurs de la
justice
les ti-cats vous arrivez à l'université
d'abidjan que vous êtes méritants pour
avoir un certain nombre d'acquis sociaux
que vous n'avez pas et que des moins
méritant que vous ont justement accès
par exemple un logement à la bouche il
faut bien dire que c'est alors on en
revient à motifs pourquoi je suis devenu
rebelle la principale raison de votre
rebellion c'est l'ivoirité lors
l'ivoirité c'est quelque chose que nous
ici en france on connaît mal c'est la
version tropicale en fait de la
préférence nationale
c'est à dire tout est de la faute des
immigrés
c'est la faute des maliens c'est la
faute des burkinabé c'est à dire les
gens du burkina faso c'est la faute des
ivoiriens du nord tirent pays dont vous
venez
enfin bref l'ivoirité c'est un petit peu
comme les théories de le pen mais
appliqués à l'afrique voilà c'est la
côte d'ivoire aux vrais ivoiriens et
bien sûr c'est accompagné de toutes ces
violences racistes qu'on peut constater
en côte d'ivoire les assassinats
politiques les massacrer tout ça et la
côte d'ivoire s'est pas l'ukraine où on
peut manifester pas un matin quand vous
hasarder à descendre dans les rues ce
sont les kalachnikovs des gendarmes qui
qui vous accueillent kitty sur vous et à
acheter du moment où cette théorie de
l'ivoirité a été consacré dans la
constitution ivoirienne
il fallait prendre ses responsabilités
il fallait décider soit de vivre et
mourir sous la torture la dictature ou
combattre et ce sont des raisons qui
nous ont amenés n'est ce pas à
programmer l'insurrection alors la
france s'est interposé entre vous et et
gbagbo c'est à dire entre vous et le
président élu de côte d'ivoire pour
créer une barrière entre le nord et le
sud
l'intervention française dit vous nous a
privés d'une victoire dire que si il est
pas eu d'intervention française
les troupes rebelles les troupes du nord
dit vous serais allé jusqu'à abidjan
auraient pris la capitale aurait pris le
pouvoir
je pense que même certaines
organisations internationales ont
reconnu la rébellion avançait sans
résistance vers le sud de la côte
d'ivoire les forces françaises sont
venues sous le prétexte pour du moins
l'argument qui a été avancé c'était doc
d'évacuer les ressortissants français de
la zone que nous contrôlions et nous
nous sommes rendu compte que au lieu
d'évacuer les ressortissants français
l'armée française a stoppé notre élan
victorieux sur abidjan et même
donner un appui logistique aux soldats
de monsieur laurent gbagbo s'étaient pas
pour la paix mais guillaume soro comment
vous expliquez que si les français lui
ont sauvé la mise l'ont sauvé la peau
qu'on vous expliquer qu'après il est
finalement dit à son peuple de virer les
ressortissants français qui habitait là
bas à abidjan et dans la région 19 savez
l'ivoirité la preuve la version
ivoirienne de la préférence nationale
on a tellement manipulé des jeunes gens
on les a instrumentalisé et il a fallu
qu'un jour le régime monsieur gbagbo
décidé d'appuyer sur le bouton français
et les jeunes
miliciens se sont dirigés contre la
communauté française qui d'ailleurs
était la plus importante en afrique de
l'ouest
est ce que la france peut encore avoir
des ressortissants en côte d'ivoire
écoutez ce sentiment anti-français qui a
été développé dans le sud de la côte
d'ivoire n'existe pas encore je vous
signale que ma voisine est une française
elle n'a jamais été agressé nous avons
longtemps vécu un bon voisinage avec le
français et il n'y a pas eu de problème
alors on a pointé un certain nombre de
dérapages quand même au sein du parti
des forces nouvelles il ya un rapport de
l'onu qui vous menace aujourd'hui de
deux poursuites judiciaires si un jour
vous êtes convoqué devant un tribunal
pénal international est ce que vous irez
guillaume c'est vrai que quand vous
pouvez contrôler une zone presque aussi
grande que la grande bretagne deux fois
le portugal il peut avoir des dérapages
et je suis sensible à tous ces dérapages
qui ont pu si j'ai dit dans notre zone
mais la fermeté que nous mettons à
combattre l'impunité est à mettre à
notre à qui mieux
l'onu a toujours reconnu dans ses
rapports que les forces nouvelles ont
toujours collaboré aux enquêtes qui ont
été menées dans notre zone donc vous
êtes prêts à reconnaître qu'il y ait des
dérapages et aller devant un tribunal
pénal international bien sûr que
personne ne peut se dérober à la justice
internationale
je considère que c'est de ma
responsabilité de répondre si je suis
convoqué alors est-ce qu'au delà de
toutes ces questions ivoirienne le
problème finalement c'est pas le
découpage de l'afrique parce que
l'afrique a été découpé par les
puissances coloniales à la fin du 19e
siècle au début du xxème est ce
qu'aujourd'hui l'afrique n'est pas en
train à travers toutes ces crises toutes
ces guerres de retrouver ses vrais
frontières qui sont des frontières
ethniques et pas des frontières décidée
par le colonisateur
je pense que le problème qui se pose le
dans le cas de la côte d'ivoire certains
problèmes de frontières je ne crois pas
c'est vrai que ces frontières ont été
tracées ça la vie de safri qu'un et que
ce sont des frontières quelquefois sur
qui divise des communautés qui divise
des familles oui parce qu'on pouvait
être entendu voir et puis avoir de la
famille au ghana je pense que ça aussi
l'une des tares de de la colonisation
mais aujourd'hui il faut aller de
l'avant parce que généralement ceux qui
tiennent ce discours mais écouter et il
ne cache pas et il nous il continue sous
le secret de d'entretenir des relations
je dirais néocolonial avec deux
puissances est ce que pour vous la
solution c'est le panafricanisme c'est à
dire finalement commis à l'europe y
aurait l'afrique qui serait une espèce
de zone comme ça où les frontières
seraient abolis absolument je pense que
l'afrique doit aller vers l'est dans un
ensemble on ne peut pas rester dans de
petits états est espérée n'est ce pas
donc acquérir le développement souhaité
voilà ça s'appelle pourquoi je suis
devenu rebelle guillaume soro
c'est chez hachette littératures alors
si un jour vous parvenez au pouvoir
guillaume est ce que vous réagirez comme
les autres est ce que vous deviendrez un
dictateur comme les autres bon je
rigolais les dictateurs en herbe st non
il est toujours difficile de parler de
soi même mais je pense que nous avons
donné l'exemple
notre rébellion à la différence des
autres rébellion n'est pas une rébellion
de pouvoir nous n'avons pas pris les
armes pour conquérir le pouvoir coûte
que coûte
nous avons pris les armes et nous avons
dit au peuple ivoirien je ne suis pas
candidat aux élections présidentielles
d'octobre 2005
ce que nous demandons c'est bien sûr des
élections démocratiques pour restaurer
la souveraineté du peuple ivoirien et
jeu
répondrai avec victor hugo pour dire que
la dictature ouvre un droit à
l'insurrection et la démocratie de le
faire donc vous n'êtes pas candidat à la
présidence une question qui risque j'ai
un amis là bas qui avait quitté abidjan
qui a épousé une ivoirienne ils ont un
enfant et je m'inquiétais beaucoup pour
lui pendant les événements et là comme
ils travaillent là bas il nous rassure
un peu en disant que ça s'est calmé mais
on sent quand même que ça peut c'est une
poudrière comme un oui je le dis dans
l'introduction de de mon livre que les
ingrédients pour un génocide sont réunis
en côte d'ivoire et c'est pourquoi ce
livre a pour vocation d'informer la
communauté nationale face elle parce que
la france a joué un grand rôle dans la
crise ivoirienne est on est on est pas
très bien informé de cette crise c'est
comme si quand est ce qu'on peut
imaginer que les américains aujourd'hui
parle si peu de falloudja ou de l'irak
comme la france le fait pour la côte
d'ivoire
je pense que ces livres doivent
permettre d'informer largement et je
vous dis qu'avec l'hiver était inconnue
voici c'est pas réglé le fils de votre
ami ne pourra jamais plus table impasse
politique en côte d'ivoire il dit dans
son bouquin c'est le rwanda en devenir
ah oui les ingrédients sont réunis c'est
maintenant que la communauté
internationale doit se montrer ferme
soit nous passons le cap avec des
élections démocratiques transparentes
incontesté ou le perdre en appel le
vainqueur pour le féliciter
ou alors c'est la catastrophe c'est le
rwanda n'ont pas levé conseillé de
rentrer donc je pense aujourd'hui que
c'est bien que votre ami soit encore en
côte d'ivoire comme ça avec la
sensibilisation qu'il peut faire autour
de vous en france ici la communauté
internationale interviendra mais il ya
une logique absurde
il ya une logique quand même sur
laquelle je m'interroge
nous avons souhaité lors du dernier
sommet que nous avons tenu à pretoria en
afrique du sud que l'onu viennent
organiser les élections
un pas du voir pour en garantir le
caractère bien sûr classe par là on nous
a répondu la côte d'ivoire n'est pas
encore un état en faillite dont l'onu ne
peut pas venir peut-être maintenant il
va falloir qu'on le met en faillite pour
que l'on devienne organiser les
élections
donc je pense que il faut que la
communauté internationale
il y a urgence que la communauté
internationale intervienne en côte
d'ivoire selon encore l'humanité portera
sur sa conscience une autre tragédie
dans mon pays merci qui et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu